er ist so schön weil ich habe euch da
vorne gar nicht gesehen weil ich so
begeistert von meinem rudi war
[Musik]
allerdings sollte nicht um diesen
wundervollen rudi gehen und auch nicht
um dieses wundervolle t shirt oder
lieben freunde denn ich darf euch heute
endlich mal wieder willkommen heißt und
seiner neuen episode tik tok tuesday
starteten standesgemäss wieder mit dem
besten tik tok der woche
[Musik]
wer also die perfekte antwort auf die
standardfrage und luca rummel verdienst
du hast dein geld nach dem studium ja
ich weiß warum ich dich vermisst haben
okay er spielt fifa hat ein pack gezogen
und hat anscheinend ein workout an alle
die kein fifa zocken das hat einen sehr
krassen spieler jetzt gezogen
oh mein gott nun
er kennt die durch daniel beckmann mit
78 zählern
vielmehr freuen
einmal haben wir auch qualität heute
dabei das ist das erste dick da wollte
wohl jemand richtig was kongresse
diesmal wird sich mein kopf frei fakten
über bäume drei fakten über bäume in
braun räumlichen hohen bäumen liegen uns
umarmt zu werden
warum die gefragt sich keiner hat sich
gefragt wie der zimmer aussieht wir
haben noch immer nicht gefragt
wir brauchen alles gut mussten
hey
ich weiß auch einfach nicht mehr was ich
dann sagen sollen es können so einer war
schwer ins haus gelaufen wenn er das
fenster aufmacht und was kommt bei mir
ein
regen und die zeugen jehovas also auf
seinem fensterrahmen befindet sich eine
maus und er weiß jetzt nicht was er
machen soll
an und irgendwie mit einem stab oder so
flach oder du setzt halt einfach deine
katze dann darauf
wir hatten komische menschen wir hatten
einen waschbären was kommt als nächstes
einen hund mit einem filter oder was
hätte ich mal einfach wie meine
kommilitonen damals auch bei irgendeinem
guten unternehmen angefangen
[Musik]
rie
habt ihr da noch ein platz frei bei euch
im unternehmen
ich würde es nur noch die toiletten
putzen ja sowas finde ich halt so nice
ich wollte eine zeit lang ein vogel
kaufen bis ich dann gesehen habe wie alt
die teile werden
ich meine ja wie geil sind vögel die
gebiete reden und und was können
menschen
sehr gut wir können auch reden
[Musik]
können wir das aufgrund von recherche
gründen noch mal an
[Musik]
ich muss ja
jawohl arbeitest du noch beim fbi
das finde ich auch immer so süß für
hunde mit so einer alltäglichen
situation plötzlich völlig überfordert
sind ich mein ok klar dagegen jetzt
irgendwie zwei meter schnee das ist
jetzt nicht so alltäglich aber auch wenn
hunde sich nicht trauen in sein kleines
tief ins badewasser bäckerei zu gehen
aber schlussendlich springen sie dann
doch in schneereichen suite und jetzt
haben den typen der mit
tischtennisbällen des partito singen
kann man sonst nichts zu tun hat ich
brauche eigentlich gar nicht sagen
wahrheit meint krieger gerade gesagt ich
soll raus kommen er will mit mir in rewe
aber es ist sonst 30 glaube die region
vergessen das geschäft war so ein idiot
wir haben keine kleinen dinge
[Musik]
so ein ding ist ich zeige euch jetzt
will man besser beim pflügen wird das
wichtigste ist dass er nicht so
antworten alex warum hast du die
hausaufgaben nicht gemacht mein hund hat
sie gefressen ihr müsst das suchen den
anderen mit euren lüge zu überraschen
alex warum hast du die hausaufgaben
nicht gemacht ich habe mein hund griff
mega korrekte gar danke für die tipps
[Applaus]
können comedians stundenlang auf einer
bühne stehen ich brauche einfach nur
john stumpf ist video mitschreiben
büchern
ja
[Musik]
gerade wirklich auf einem guten weg
ihren kummer wieso das denn keine
diskussion wies auch okay bin ich
beruhigt das kannst du wieder reinkommen
ok ich glaub mein humors sitzengeblieben
in der dritten klasse morgen an zweiten
klasse sitzen geblieben
offiziell eine legende entwicklung
denker das einzige was an den gern das
ist ein schnupper das opfer herzlich
willkommen im tik tok kindergarten was
ja auch ganz gut zu pass es einen
livestream der mir zu gesendet wurde
denn dort hat ein mädchen einfach von
ihrer mutter den satz gesagt bekommen
hey du mir geht es nicht gut
ich kann nicht richtig atmen lasse man
ins krankenhaus fahren aber ich spiele
euch mal die komplette szene ab und auch
die reaktion von dem mädchen
[Musik]
dieser gut
hat gerade einfach komplett hector cops
genommen ich habe ihm eine cafeteria
getöteten ich glaub ich wurde gesehen
erinnerst du dich an die farbe was
meinst du welche farben naja was können
spieler ist welche spieler wie möglich
das spiel kommen allerdings zu guter
letzt einen tick tock account die ich
vor einigen tagen entdeckt habe und er
mich zum lachen gebracht hat das möchte
ich einfach wirklich nicht vorenthalten
mitte diesen sitz punkt stehen klar
sitzt das ist diana aller das ist der
süden
abwehrchef 06 in deutsch sechs hatte ich
hab doch gelernt
was machen mich die hosen tick keine
ahnung aber essen wirklich für mich
gut dass wir kein
an ihr sind any warum wir können gar
kein spanisch
es ist erfreulich wie jetzt allerdings
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
euch luca reagiert oft x-mal wieder
gefallen hat dann lassen einen daumen
hoch und ein video hier da keine
kommentare von mir sind
selbstverständlich nicht böse gemeint
ich hab das war jetzt falsch formuliert
von mir aber ich möchte keiner person
was böse sind auch der kanal gehört am
ende ich feiere den eigentlich wieder
falsches deutsch hat ist aber auch
scheiße gar nicht wird sagen wir sind
uns im nächsten video wieder wenn es
wieder einmal
[Musik]